. All right, this is sort of like an inside kind
of adding insult to injury type story. One thing
that's become clear in the first couple of months
of Joe Biden's presidency is that he truly doesn't
seem to care about a lot of these vanity elements
that were very important to the former president,
things like television ratings or Joe Biden's
signature being on the covid relief checks
that are starting to go out now. And we know
that those things were very, very important to
Donald Trump. And yet Joe Biden's first primetime
national address on Thursday night during which
he announced every adult will be eligible
for a vaccine by May 1st. In all 50 states,
that Biden event got higher ratings and more
viewership than Donald Trump's first address as
president. About eighteen point two million people
watched Joe Biden's speech on broadcast networks
compared to Donald Trump's first one, which
seventeen point seven million viewers watched.
About half a million more people watched the
Joe Biden event than watched the Donald Trump
event. And the best part about this to
me is that Joe Biden clearly doesn't care
about any of it. But it's also particularly funny
because one of Donald Trump's main campaign lines
against Joe Biden was there's just no energy
around Joe. I show up and do huge rallies and
Joe had ten people in cars. They're honking.
And of course, this was by design. Joe Biden,
because of the pandemic, decided it wouldn't be
responsible to do what Donald Trump was doing.
And that's the explanation. We also know, as we
learned from the Democratic primary, as much as
we did from the general election in November, that
tweets and Facebook posts and rally crowds don't
necessarily tell you who actually has more support
in reality. And Joe Biden got millions more votes
than Donald Trump. But Biden ends up without
even caring, kind of beating Donald Trump at
his own game without even playing the game, if you
can imagine that. And as much as we know, Donald
Trump is upset about Joe Biden getting credit
for the vaccination rollout, which Donald Trump,
you might remember last week, put out a statement
saying, please remember that I should get credit
for the vaccines as much as Trump is upset
that things are actually starting to improve
finally on the virus. What makes Trump really
upset is that he's not getting attention anymore.
And Joe Biden is. And as hilarious as it is
that Joe Biden got better ratings than Trump,
it's something that Trump is
primarily the one who cares about.
The Biden administration hasn't even talked about
this fact because it really doesn't seem Biden
cares about ratings and marks, so to speak. And
you can tell from the reactions from right wingers
that we looked at earlier in the show that
they are also struggling with how to respond.
Some right wingers have decided to focus in on Joe
Biden has dementia. He seemed demented during his
speech. He didn't even know where he was during
the speech, during which he announced, hey, guys,
we're accelerating vaccination so much that
by May 1st, every adult will be eligible for a
vaccine. They couldn't they didn't want to focus
on the substance. So instead they said, oh, Joe,
Joe Biden didn't even know he was at the White
House during the speech. Others focused on how
dare Joe Biden politicize the Fourth of July
by saying we will probably be able to have
safe cookouts and barbecues on July 4th. Others
focused on how dare Joe Biden not get down on his
knees and pray to Trump for creating the vaccines
that Biden is now rolling out. And of course,
earlier we said Trump really doesn't deserve any
credit for the vaccines. And then other right
wingers have focused on fear mongering about Joe
Biden. Expanding vaccination this month is a clear
pretext for forcing everybody to get vaccinated,
which obviously. Is not going to happen,
and it's not what the administration is doing. It
was just like a good simple political speech with
Joe Biden communicating vaccination is improving
significantly. It will continue improving.
And every aspect of that speech has the right
absolutely furious. And then more people watching
it than the number of people that watch Donald
Trump's first address is just kind of like a pile
on at this point. But there's an interesting story
to the ratings that goes beyond Trump's obsession
with ratings. When every presidential speech
was like out of this world, wacky, cartoonish,
for four straight years, a normal speech has
actually become sort of interesting. People
wrote to me, dozens of people saying, you
know, it wasn't that I watched the Biden
speech with you or on a network or whatever,
because I expected fireworks. I didn't most
people didn't even expect the expansion
of vaccination to 18 plus by May 1st.
People basically wrote to me and said I wanted
to see a president just kind of behave normally,
communicate in a normal way what is going on, and
that it might get tougher before it gets better.
And Joe Biden even saying if this doesn't go as
well as we're hoping for, I'm going to tell you,
I'm not going to lie to you and say it all went
well. If it didn't go well. And there's been
an absence of that in the United States for
four years. And I think that's as big a part
of what we are seeing in terms of these TV
ratings for the Biden event. As anything else